um one of the things I found reading the
books and of course watching the series
is I have a lot of friends who have
children and they struggle for months
months on how to name one child one
child and you sir have named thousands
of people where where does the
inspiration for these names come from
because they there's the why I mean
you've got the John Snow and then you've
got crazy exotic names as well where do
you find all the inspiration for the
names names are very hard I bet this is
an interesting question yeah names names
are really really hard and I need to
know the name of a character before I
can write about them I've met a writer
once I won't I won't mention her name
she's very successful science fiction
fantasy writer but I remember years ago
I happened to be visiting her in their
house and they were so long ago she was
working on her IBM Selectric so it gives
you an idea of how long didn't have
computers yet and she was finishing a
novel and I noticed that they were like
no names
there was like X 13 X 13 turn away you
dig the character X 13 - oh no no I I
have a hard time with names so I put
them in at the end I see I have this
list where I number all the characters
like a 1 a 2 a 3 and then I write the
book with that and then when I'm done I
invent names for them and use the search
and you know I you know just well for
put X 13 is Fred and then Fred appears I
can't write about Fred unless I know
that his name was Fred you know I mean
knowing that he's Fred influences the
whole way I write about him and and so
forth so so that method of working you
know different writers work different
ways that was completely alien for me
but one of the things about names when
you're when you're a wee tiny little
writer just starting out one of the
things they teach you is when you're
writing a story never give two
characters in the story names that begin
with the same letter because the reader
will confuse them and I followed that
rule for many years but then when I was
writing Ice and Fire I said wait a
minute I'm planning on having more than
26 characters
Wow what am I gonna do here am I gonna
named him like X Fred or so I decided to
ignore that rule in fact I decided
reading history I decided to go even
further if it's bad to name two
characters characters names that start
with the same letter it's really bad to
give two characters the same story the
same name so I looked at you know
reading English history which was
inspiration for that if you read English
history and you guys are Canadians I
presume you know a little of English
history everybody ended is named Edward
and Henry it's really you know the
history of England is a history of
Edward and Henry and occasionally
richard sneaks in and does a little
mischief and somehow yet we keep them we
attach numbers to them we attach you
know secondary names you know Edward of
Woodstock Henry of York or whatever and
we're able to distinguish one from the
other or with nicknames and I said you
know I'm gonna do that that's much more
realistic I'm gonna have these these
family names and and like many families
I know in the real world there'll be I'm
naming UF your grandmother I'm naming
you after your grandfather there was
this great king and you want to curry
favor so of course you're you're gonna
name your child after the king and I
wanted to show all these naming patterns
and they all occur in in the book why
will you see you know Robert comes to
the throne and a lot of children around
the same time suddenly seem to have the
name Robert in numerous families but you
also see families like the Starks who
keep having a brand in every every
generation every other generation
there's a Brandon of some sort going
back to their ancestor bran the Builder
and the Lannisters who always have to
tea why you know Tywin him all to Tyrion
so forth so the echoes of family names
and family naming patterns I also wanted
to show the ethnic groups so
you know the the I have successive waves
of invasion that have hit Westeros in
this backstory if you read its history
and of course they started out with the
first man and and the first men tend to
have very simple descriptive names like
stark or strong or mud or you know where
they're named after something and then
the Andals come in and their names are a
little more elaborate and they don't
tend to be named after things so like
Lannister or Aaron these are these are
handled names and then of course you get
the the Valerians and the Targaryen is
coming in who have the very exotic names
with all the AES and the Y's and the odd
spellings like Daenerys Targaryen which
was a pretty exotic name I thought and
this spoke an exotic past that went well
with the silver hair and the purple eyes
and so forth it is somewhat startling
that I receive all these baby pictures
on the emails of little girls who are
being named Daenerys and you know in a
few more years probably the first wave
of them has already hit kindergarten by
now
there must be kindergarten teachers all
over the United States and Canada
cursing my name and they say I don't
know you spell my name with an A E and a
Y at the end
[Laughter]